chose promise chose due dès demain six
transporteurs aériens mettront en vente
des billets à 500 dollars pour les
voyages personnels dans les régions du
québec il y en aura tout près de 100000
par année honnêtement ce sera un franc
succès sont réussis et je le souhaite
vendre ses 98 mille billets sur une
année complète ces billets seront
disponibles pour les vols au départ ou à
destination de trois aéroports québec
montréal et saint-hubert pour les
voyageurs des régions éloignées comme
l'abitibi le saguenaylac côte nord où la
gaspésie qui voyageront sans passer par
l'un des trois principaux aéroports un
autre programme remboursera jusqu'à 60%
du coût de leurs billets et le temps
même pujol qui m'ont demandé pourquoi
ceci pourquoi pas cela alors nous ce qui
est important c'est de s'assurer de
bonifier et d'assurer la pérennité de
ses dessertes dans les prochaines années
lors de leurs achats les voyageurs
devront s'engager à respecter la limite
annuelle de trois allers retours à 500 $
ou 6 allers simples à 250 dollars une
offre alléchante pour bien des gens avis
à la rame puis j'ai pas eu l'occasion
d'aller la voir encore le depuis ces
dernières années parce que c'est très
onéreux c'était très onéreux depuis ce
succès encourage beaucoup mais pour
d'autres comme cette résidente des îles
de la madeleine il pourrait y avoir des
effets indésirables
il ya déjà assez de touristes viennent
l'été donc ce serait bien son cours et
est en assénant touristique sur toute
l'année à la place mais le présentement
le domaine on note besoin les
transporteurs aériens et espère que le
programme ramènera des voyageurs après
la période difficile de la pandémie mais
déjà il anticipe que la compensation
offerte par le gouvernement entre le
tarif à 500 $ et le coût réel du billet
devra être revue à la hausse prix du
carburant un triplé sur 12 - doublé
depuis le gars du blogueur en ukraine
les transporteurs aériens sont prêts à
donner une chance à ce programme qui est
doté d'une enveloppe de 38 millions de
dollars pour l'année à venir mais si le
volume de passagers n'est pas au rendez
vous certains n'hésiteront pas à mettre
un terme à leur participation ici
alexandre duval radio canada québec